hey what's up beautiful people welcome
to the episode of get close I am your
host Geo and I'm Bart and today we have
a very special guest we have miss queen
okay she's a princess Miss Princess Mia
she's our new addition to our family our
adopted little fur baby she's five
months and oh my God I love you so much
so she's here so if you're listening and
you want to see what she looks like jump
on over to our YouTube channel she's our
Wolf princess she's a little Wolf
princess and it's been a hectic few
months
um you know we've gone through so much I
don't want to repeat all of it because
just thinking about it again stresses me
the F out
um like even something as small as
getting these window shades installed
like we used to have like what was it
like black like a black piece of paper
over yeah yeah when we first moved in
right now we're like like it feels like
life is coming back together yeah and
throughout all of this craziness and all
these ups and downs and these crazy
[ __ ] waves and it just feels
like
God's been just like shaking some [ __ ]
up yeah you've remained this person
really steady like a rock you really
think I'm pretty calm for the most part
like you'll have stressful days but like
the amount of of emotional
wavering I don't know emotional
fluctuations fluctuation it's very
minimal with you like
yeah look like this is you the house is
burning and then you'll be like ma bear
get your stuff the house is burning what
about when I go like I'm very horny
right now we're gonna have lots of sex
lots of intercourse lots of intercourse
yeah I mean yeah you're riled up yeah I
can't control myself at all right now
you're like my pants are getting
extremely tight in the crotch area yes
therefore we must conjugate I don't know
I'm leaking
you [ __ ] robot and that's kind of
like when I tease you right and I call
you a robot
um it's because you're just so steady
all the time like emotionally study I
don't know what's going on in that small
forehead of yours but like
how do you do it I don't as I as far as
I date as I as I can what do you think
what we're talking about are we dating
carbon dating yeah okay as far back as I
can remember I've been like calm
compared to all of what's going on
around how far back are you reminding
I think as far back as I can think
I'm thinking maybe even my first grade
you're six yeah like ever since I was
six I remember like stuff would happen
and um I would see like let's say like
a crazy dog like running into the
playground at school and then like the
kids are screaming or going crazy some
are excited some are like scared and I
would just be like in my mind I think
I'm expressing the same thing but maybe
the outside or in my mind I'm feeling
the same thing but on the outside I'm
just looking like oh that's a CUNY dog
yeah but what are you doing and what are
you wearing I'm probably just standing
there with a bowl cut of some sort I'm
just staring at the doctor because I
just picture you being like that awkward
kid in all black with like something
black yeah yeah yeah like you're just
like a [ __ ] Outcast of All Sorts so
usually the outcasts have to dress like
an outcast yeah granted you're in first
grade so you're probably not picking
your clothes but like I just picture you
being that dark you know what I used to
wear in first grade
just like matching sweatsuits that's
when my mom was sent me to school then
that's tight no they're not tight why
don't you drink oh cause I was pretty
sure heather gray like no no no no no no
no with a little jogger action and some
like high top sneakers no she only
bought clothes at the swap meet so
they're all fake
so it'll be like I remember one of my uh
the ones that my mom addressed me in is
like this yellow
um yellow quarter zip fleece so the
zipper only goes down to here and it was
like some fake dragon ball that no one
ever seen and then my pants are also
yellow
so my mom would just buy I think because
it was easy
no one no one's trying to STEEZ it up in
first grade but it looks ugly but I just
look I either look like I was part of
the Armenian Mafia because I'm always
wearing sweat suits top and bottom the
Chinese boy in The Armenian Mafia yeah
always miss uh matching ugly fake
sweatsuits yeah dude my mom so we didn't
grow up with much a lot of money so my
mom would get really creative with how
she would get our clothes yeah
um unfortunately I have so not
unfortunately that I have for three
other siblings but it's unfortunate that
we had such big age gaps so me and my
oldest sister's 15 years me and my older
brother it's 10 years so there was no
such thing as hand-me-downs for me
because it'd be like a decade old oh I
see yeah so my mom's not gonna keep
something in a box for 10 years you know
she probably didn't even know she's
gonna get pregnant again
so she knew because my mom was a teacher
she would just know a lot of moms and
stuff and a lot of these moms are pretty
crafty so one mom in particular would
make her own clothes so she would make
like a short and like shirt set or just
like little like leggings and it all
would match but it was the [ __ ]
ugliest patterns like it was so [ __ ]
like you could tell that these like this
fabric which was like Joanne's and buys
it yeah something like that and my mom
would get me so many of these because
the sets were probably like three to
five bucks because the lady's just
charging her for materials you know
she's not charging her all the other
fees yeah
um and I used to be like [ __ ] because I
think it was like fourth grade fourth
grade you already start knowing like
who's season and who's not like that's
when it began for me I remember in third
grade you know what the first thing that
caught my eye was a lady no you never uh
tireless shoelaces have you seen those
that's when I first realized what
Steve's was velcro or tylus shoelaces
so there's this kid you know you know
the um the thing that teachers have it's
like a almost like the back of a spiral
notebook and you can stretch and they
they I gave one of those to Tyga today
yeah so that's like it's curly anything
yeah yeah the keys yes they made
shoelaces like that and I remember this
one how geeky no no no this kid he
pulled up to recess he put he laid his
foot down
he grabbed the two shoestrings
pulled it just let it go the shoes were
tight the two long laces curled up and I
was like
[ __ ] that's the steeziest [ __ ] I've ever
seen in my whole life yeah you know what
it is you know what he did he did it
twice boom
boom yeah and he was ready to go yeah
you know what's happening to this kid
what he only wears velcro shoes now why
nobody [ __ ] taught him how to type oh
he has shoelaces he has the crystals
yeah but he doesn't have to tie them he
doesn't know how to tie a knot
he didn't do the [ __ ] bunny ears
around the house I think he already
mastered it and he's on the next level
no I don't I think he was ahead of the
curve not behind the curve okay okay
um
uh so that's as far back as you remember
I've always put some [ __ ] that happened
back then that you were like
I mean now that you have to think about
it where you're just like oh [ __ ] I was
actually pretty pretty calm
if if uh if I had to put my finger on it
please
I think it's like the extreme ass
beatings I got
so I think I had to like really endure a
lot of pain and then so I think it
helped me kind of separate me from my
Sensations
so I've been able to kind of create like
a gap almost like a you know like a
insulated thermos when you buy one of
those nice Hydro flasks like the reason
why it stays that temperature is because
you pour the water in it's inside like a
stainless tube then there's air and then
the outside stainless tube so I have
that air between my Sensations and who I
am so I think that's that I come ask me
a lot that's so [ __ ] tragic but it
made me calm
um Okay so
excuse me so for me I can walk myself
through the times that allowed me to
either become an an uh what is it when
you're just like uh what is it [ __ ]
when you're just thinking to yourself
introspective person yeah like I
remember those times where I would have
to draw
to that part of my brain and just like
really just reason with myself
do you have those I'm always
introspective not introspective but more
so the ass beatings where you had to
separate feeling from your body
I think I try to yeah yeah but I'm just
saying like do you have that memory
where you're just like okay time to go
into [ __ ]
um I don't know Buddhist mode and like
or monk mode and now just be one
with I don't know I tried to but you're
a kid you know so like my mom I stand
still and I'll get hit once you got this
I can't boom and another one ah now I'm
like running all over the house I'm like
God damn [ __ ] damn this is [ __ ] crazy
you know jumping on the bed jumping
through the living room running in the
backyard running to the front yard
almost just back in there just [ __ ]
whip my ass again I'm playing all
running all over the place yeah I'm
going [ __ ] room to room to bathroom
everywhere no wonder your mom's
endurance is so good
like we're chasing each other on the
house it's like that except she's
beating my ass I'm literally running
around the kitchen table like 20 times
just like a jazz back here which only
pisses off the parent even more I don't
and I jump on the couch and jump over I
jump into gold when your dog runs away
and you're like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
get your [ __ ] ass back here and they
think you're [ __ ] playing yeah go in
the garage go in the backyard in the
alley yeah but the mamas want me to
cause a scene so if I run to the front
yard and you just have to like pretend
it's all good yeah
I think there's that and then the
extreme Buddhist upbringing so all the
meditation that my mom used to do which
is daily so I'll just sit there for like
30 minutes or an hour so I think it um
allowed me to like
get centered and recalibrate really
quickly damn
you need to teach me that
I'm a [ __ ] ball of emotion like I'm
just a bag of just all these sorts of
emotion and if you just shake it up a
little bit I'm like I think you're
hopeless
I'm not hopeless well you're Latin
yeah we do have a lot of fire we got to
take the good with the bad baby you
gotta take the good with the bad baby
have you ever met a calm Latin person I
don't think they exist
but then we'd be boring
like who gets the party popping baby so
how are you gonna ever gonna be calm
like I mean I'm just I just want to pick
your brain I just want to see how other
people live okay okay yeah for me look
at this red baby like I I [ __ ] I
[ __ ] love to like pop you know what
I'm saying
I like the fiesta yeah yeah but I'm just
so curious because I just can't relate
to that
I really can't I think the only time
I've been able to no even then I didn't
do it I was thinking of the time why not
we thought to when tiger had his second
seizure that we didn't know that it was
a seizure we thought he was choking on
something
and I remember you're like call 9-1-1
even at that point taika's like lifeless
not lifeless but he's pretty limp in
your arms and you're like taika taika
trying to give him CPR and like you're
like call 9-1-1 obviously your voice is
slightly elevated but you're not
freaking out really yeah I thought I was
freaking out yeah well probably because
you were like screaming a little bit we
were like call 9-1-1 and then I was just
like okay and I'm like 911 and I was
pretty calm and then I was like come get
here I gave him the situation I I the
first thing I did was give the address
and then
um because I was scared something was
gonna happen like we get disconnected or
something so I'm like just get the
information you need right away because
I need your ass here and then I just
remember going ah
I remember
there's just so much you know what's
helpful too is the training though so
I've been in a lot of enough Boy Scouts
and lifeguard training in the Marine
Corps and stuff just to like know kind
of like some [ __ ] happens there's like
the one two three I uh I oh what is it
called I'm caring for the patient
you send someone to get help and then
you get a third person to like stand
watch or something if there's like
you're under under Fire or whatever
right so like when I had taika and I was
trying to do CPR and I couldn't open his
mouth and blowing through his nose I
talked to your mom first I'm like Ma
call 9-1-1 but her [ __ ] like
arthritis ass she was like I can't [ __ ]
you I can't and then she's still trying
to press 9-1-1 I was like get [ __ ]
Geo because I know you're you're [ __ ]
sexy ass was naked in the shower real
quick
and then the soap suds were like going
in every crevice yeah and every cut and
I was like I was blowing to Tiger's nose
and I was like
right exactly come out naked yeah and I
was like yeah so like that helped out
because I always know that any any time
some [ __ ] happens you need to hit the
one two three you know you're thinking
of all that I think it's muscle memory
now it's like a dress what's happening
and whoever is the closest and is going
to be the ringleader is going to
quarterback it address what's happening
and then immediately get a professional
on board that's like and then if you
have a third person you go your ass get
on the street because as soon as the
cops or the paramedics come in you're
the one walking them through you know so
that way it's like we got that relay
erase going
and so when when that happened I think I
let that out but inside I thought I've
never dude your [ __ ] son I thought
that like looks like it was about to be
yeah
[ __ ] I felt like my world was gonna end
I felt so scared I was like holy [ __ ]
I'm gonna lose this guy this is like my
favorite guy in the whole universe the
needle guy yeah and I'm like he's like
my whole purpose of living hey what
about me no he's my whole purpose of
living and then I'm like this guy good
answer this guy [ __ ] dies like what
am I gonna do am I gonna jump off a
bridge too am I gonna bust the future
pops or something you know that's
oh my God I don't know I don't know
what's gonna happen so I was like God
damn like my life worth even living are
you just talking about your [ __ ] Dad
yeah because I was living for my son and
I'm like man if is like what do I do
I'm like I was so I was so scared so sad
so I was just like trying to get your
[ __ ] West Side mom to [ __ ] down
stop talking [ __ ] about my mom okay and
she she couldn't and then she finally
got you and then you came in like like a
storm and I was actually surprised at I
know how crazy you are usually like
unstable and bipolaresque I'm not
bipolar I'm just [ __ ] a Latina dude
in the state of the emergency instead of
like
yeah like you're actually like pop pop
pop and you're doing what you needed to
do too I thought that was pretty dope
even with the soap suds on your titties
I know I busted out naked but
um yeah that was actually pretty I was
pretty uh proud of myself that was
probably one of the craziest moments
I've been through with you I think [ __ ]
yeah we've never been through anything
like
and then your brother said I was like
after the cops in the paramedics came he
felt like he said I was pretty calm yeah
the whole time you were calm yeah and I
was pretty pissed because I was like I
was pretty calm too why didn't I get
that coming
you know what I also think I think I've
also realized like when [ __ ] hits the
fan
you can either be the anchor or you
could be the ship
and then if you're the ship and you're
getting rocked by the waves it's very
unproductive yeah but if you could find
an anchor I realized the anchoring
builds momentum in a positive direction
yeah so I think like even when we got
tiger stabilized the medical
professionals come I know what they're
looking for so I immediately find like
they're shock collar they're paramedic
gut and give the [ __ ] guy that
stutters I know that guy but I was
talking to another guy I give him like I
can already tell he's trying to take the
notes but I'm like you don't look like
you're the chief that guy looks like
he's the chief so I go to him and I give
him play-by-play instructions of what I
know and then so that he can take that
because I know he has to write his
report and I know he has to phone it
into the hospital to get the whole relay
race going you know
so I think like in times like that
um it helps out being the Anchor Point
and uh I think it's also very similar to
like surfing and like Boogie boarding
too and what in what regard so he's a
big ass wave and you're getting yeah
yeah like sometimes you don't like Duck
dive properly and you get caught up in
the wave and the worst thing you can do
is kind of like try to grasp something
but then you're not going to be stronger
than the wave it's just going to Tumble
you what up guys this episode is brought
to you by the one and only manscapes and
what I have in my hand is the lawnmower
4.0 which I use religiously every week
to keep myself nice and trimmed and
presentable and ready to make taika's
brother or sister you know what I'm
saying and that's what I love about
manscape because they have a whole
plethora of options to keep the dude
let's face it dudes are kind of nasty
more appealing to ourselves and our
significant others and if you guys are
looking for gift ideas this is perfect
because they have a ton of stocking
stuffers so for example like the
Platinum package 4.0 comes loads of
little presents perfect for stocking
stuffers like a handful of the liquid
formulations shampoos body washes
upstairs and downstairs deodorants gels
exfoliants they're shears 2.0 is their
full kit for Nail Care which I also use
has scissors Clippers tweezers ever
traveling and you need to keep your
grooming under control boom nice easy
package throw in your backpack and
you're ready to go you don't have to
worry about throwing out your crazy nose
hairs or you have like cat like
fingernails or anything like that also
they have the persevere cologne which is
a light Breezy woodsy feel gives that
fresh tree scent even after the holidays
are over because you always want to
smell fresh and they also have a body
buffer which you can use to scrub your
skin and right now if you use the code
get close you get 20 off at checkout
plus free shipping and we all know with
the increase of gas prices how much
shipping can be so make sure you use
that code get close to get 20 percent
off plus free shipping to buy yourself a
gift or a gift for someone else
manscaped but that just sounds like
um a lot of thinking
you actually let go
you actually go let go
and then you cover your head so your
head doesn't hit the floor and you just
kind of go with the flow but then it's a
it's a skillful let go yeah it's not
like ah I'm just gonna let my I'm just
gonna emote it's more like I let go and
then let the training or muscle memory
take over you know yeah versus trying to
like uh like you know hold on yeah what
about in those cases where there is no
training
like you're specifically referring to
Boogie boarding and surfing right where
hopefully it's not your first time doing
it you're probably gonna do that right
but over time you do develop that muscle
memory but in a situation where where
it's not like that how what do you tap
into
or like how would you even instruct
someone to be like the commonality of it
relax the commonality of it so like I
think people get caught up in specific
moments and I think that's when they
feel like they're at a loss of skill set
because they're thinking well I had a
fire at my house and then
um my kid fell off the slide
but and then they think I'm not trained
for this I'm not trained for that but
you're actually trained yeah if you've
done this you've been trained for a
frightful moment focus on the frightful
moment in finding anchoring in the
frightful moment
you get what I'm saying I do but it just
sounds like so I can only relate it to
myself because I only know how I feel I
will never understand how anyone else
feels so in those crazy moments I'm not
thinking about all that stuff I'm not
either but that's why I'm even Primal I
think people aren't Primal enough shout
outs to liver king
um oh really yeah yeah I don't think the
Nettie King yeah I think people are
really like
um dealing with what's visceral I think
they're dealing with what's in here so
that's why they're separated no but that
fire is different than this fire and
that fire is different to this fire if
you know the sense of danger that's it
doesn't matter if you're getting robbed
or something's exploding address the
sense of danger
so for example you know in that cooking
book like what is it salt acid fat heat
yeah yeah yeah yeah right so like that's
why like um when people are cooking they
go I need something citrusy oh I don't
got limes you know what I'll do a splash
of vinegar uh Splash ponzu right or like
oh it needs like some depth I need some
sort of fat oh I got olive oil douse the
salad I think like that at all I don't
have olive oil I don't have olive oil
um get some butter I'll get some butter
or throw some bacon in there boom now
the dish has body has body to it you
know so like the way that I see it is we
all see oh but that's past that and
that's dumplings and that's chicken
fried rice
but what really what it is is just all
cooking is for visceral things salt Heat
acid fat same thing with our emotions
you're happy or whatever or whatever so
I always resort to that and I address
that and then so if I've been in a
boogie boarding thing and I've been a
tumbleweed and I know what danger feels
like and I know how to shrink and
protect my head
then when taika is having a seizure
that's that new Tumbleweed and I know
okay what's how do I shrink and protect
my head in this situation that's how
I've always liked I guess I live my life
like metaphors and analogies so if I
experience one thing
it helps me understand something else
do you not operate that
um
it is so [ __ ] at
again I'm more like
I'm trying to I just don't feel like I
think like that oh so for me it's as
simple as
um
when shit's hitting the fan I have to
like tell myself stop
and I'm not talking about like when I'm
about to like bust the Latina on you and
like just go crazy before I know the
full information I just start yelling at
you yeah that's not like that that's
very Latina yeah yeah not like that yeah
but when it's like a real [ __ ]
emergency type of situation I always
have to tell myself like stop because I
just know that if I just keep like
moving forward in that state I'm gonna
[ __ ] up so I have to tell myself stop
and when you say stop to you like like
really you physically and mentally stop
like literally it's possible unless I'm
like driving a [ __ ] car yeah but like
stop more so in my thoughts
like whatever because you you know you
panic you're already thinking of this
this this this like holy [ __ ] you know
what I mean like he's about to die I'm
about to fall this thing oh my God I
can't do that okay like you're thinking
a million thoughts at once so I just
have to clear my brain like I just have
to say stop
okay what are we doing like I have to
talk to myself that slow so when the
thing happened with taika and you're
like call 9-1-1 I'm seeing all this
stuff and I'm already going like oh my
God like I'm about to lose my son and
then I have to say stop and then I have
to hear what you're saying
because I'm if I don't say stop I'm just
going off the rails that's pretty cool
you know what my version of that is what
you know in those movies where like
you're getting a car crash and not slow
motion yeah and then there's like
ketchup packets flying and stuff like
that I think everyone when they go
through something traumatic of course
it's slow like that so I think how I
slow myself down it's kind of like that
where I go
I'm gonna hold my breath and as soon as
I hold my breath the world goes like
that right and then that way you can
kind of go like
slow motion yeah and then once I think I
like am able to kind of do things in
slow motion then I go
and then execute yeah yeah
same that's pretty cool yeah but with me
um that's why how come you'll deal with
me though why do you just why do you
just like jump to jump to conclusion
just start [ __ ] spraying all kinds of
nonsense out of your dirty mouth dirty
little [ __ ] mouth you know
you're stupid
um why don't I do that with you it's
just it's Petty like it's not even
important you know I just let it go
because it takes so much energy so when
going back to that that example because
that was where you really saw my true
colors like I can't front at that point
like you're gonna know if I'm a [ __ ] or
not right like a little [ __ ] wussy
wussy yeah um or just a [ __ ] [ __ ]
show right like now you know that you
can count on me if [ __ ] hits the fan
right right yeah that's right okay good
so
um because it takes so much for me to
like say stop and actually quiet
everything so that I can think one
thought at a time
that's why when I'm waiting and I have
time to actually think and there's not
enough things moving quickly enough then
all the thoughts start seeping back in
that that's when I think I screamed
because that I couldn't I couldn't tell
myself to stop anymore because the
thoughts were just coming in so much
today physically shaking clear it up
yeah so kind of like a dog like when
they you know what like if they get hurt
or they're pissed and they just shake
and then it resets them I think that's
why I needed to scream because it was
just so intense that I'm like holy [ __ ]
I need to do something because I my
thoughts are just getting ahead of me so
I was like
and once I did that I'm like okay I'm
back good now what do we do it's scuba
diving it's called clearing your
regulator go
because you could feel the water coming
back in you press the button and you
clear at night
[ __ ] I could never scuba dive
you can't I think you'll love it oh God
and and the fact that I said I could
never
you felt like a little [ __ ] I just
did I did because I'm like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] like oh really you could never I
think you would [ __ ]
love it I'm afraid of the dark though
you know how deep you have to go to be
dark
I mean in California it's pretty shallow
generally you're not gonna see like
complete darkness like that but you
would [ __ ] love it and once you
master or not master uh but once you get
comfortable scuba diving I think you'll
be really chill in a lot of situations
because scuba it's one of those like
you're literally surviving by a one inch
tube 50 feet under water well you sold
it but you take baby steps to get there
oh of course and then you know so
there's like
um
and you just have to always remain at a
state of calm because if your heart rate
goes up you're gonna suck all your air
you might run out of air before you get
to the top so you know I have to remain
calm all the time so you're like even
when you're moving you're trying to like
right and then sometimes you swim
through a kelp like I've ran swam
through a kelp forest and the kelp just
pulled my goggles right off my face uh
so now your eyes are like cold as [ __ ]
because the water's really cold and now
it's like needles and then it pulled my
regulator out of my mouth and you're
just like
let's chill I
no no big deal just 50 feet underwater
with no air you know and then you just
kind of like
you're like oh silly kelp
[ __ ] all that hey bikini dude uh in
Hawaii we're we're just what is that
called snorkeling yeah and I'm like
still like half of my body is out of the
water and the other half is in the water
and let's say I'm like about to swim
through a school of fish and they'd look
like the most like docile of fishes yeah
and they're cute and they're all tiny
and [ __ ]
um I'm like about I'm like oh I'm about
to like swim right next to them yeah and
then as soon as I get closer I'm like I
don't know anything about this
[ __ ] species and I go the
opposite direction because I'm like [ __ ]
all that like what if they just I don't
know they won't do anything I don't know
I don't even know what you are
you know they just go oh there's a blob
just swimming by I don't even know what
that is yeah they sure are pretty stupid
I'm just kidding but no that that's why
I'm like
why where everything is crystal clear
and like colorful and like Pleasant yeah
I still get scared
I see I don't know if I could do it I
think you can I think in some ways um a
lot of the meditation my mom had me do
as a kid really helped out because it's
like just finding your Center you know
like regardless of anything so like
what does that mean finding your Center
the way the best way I think that I can
visually describe is when you're like
Boogie boarding or surfing and you get
caught in a way for someone that's never
done it aka me like how do I find my
Center what does that mean
um
or even like uh like when are you out of
Center what does that mean and then when
are you in Center when you're out of
Center is when you're getting rocked by
the boat
like something has happened and you are
not in control and you're reacting
instead of being proactive I see so like
last night when I was all crying and
[ __ ] because I'm gonna about to start my
period and I'm super emotional it was
just you're trying to explain something
and then I was just like crying is that
out of Center
that's outer Center I mean but that's
extra hard because your biology is not
working in your favor at that moment
yeah but that's out of Center you know I
think it's like like let's say you you
smash a card in a car accident and
you're like about to freak out versus a
lot of parents what do they do they go
put their hand in front of the kid
that's centered uh I see I see you know
okay like being not being not being like
reactive or so like
like you're just you're now at the at
the whim of what's happening it's like
okay how do I
like take control of this situation oh
okay right even like earthquake we learn
in school duck under the desk I think
that's wrong now really I think so I
think it's different I don't know I
think it works so you grab a PO the way
that I was taught you get underneath a
table or something strong and you hold
on to the post so that way that thing
doesn't like move away from you yeah and
it protects your head right so that's
that's like Center like what's what's a
point that you can anchor yourself in
this situation
and once you can anchor yourself in a
situation you can build on top of that
anchor but if you're not anchored you're
always gonna be you know it's like oh
that's why in movies when like the
person's freaking out and they [ __ ]
have to slap them get get it together
man yeah or in the visual of like you
know your airplane movies where like the
back of the airplane blows out right and
then everyone's flying out and then
everyone's like you see luggage whatever
I'm not gonna get on goddamn airplane
anytime soon they're flying out what
does the hero do he's like grabs onto
one chair and then once he has it he has
one Anchor Point now now you can build
on top of it one hand turns into two
hands two hands gets him up maybe he
ties himself now you can help someone
else right but if you're still at the
whim of the broken airplane man your
[ __ ] analogies are so good yeah if
you're at the whim of the broken
airplane you're [ __ ] you're not saving
nobody you're not and you're not even
saving yourself so that's I think like
for me when I but maybe because I'm calm
because like I look for that Anchor
Point you know even in jits right
someone got a rear naked on you if it's
tight tight and you're just panicking ah
you're [ __ ] but if you can stick one
finger in oh
if I can stick one finger in and I could
peel one finger off maybe I could stick
two fingers in peel two fingers off you
know like just finding that one thing
what's that one thing that is this like
I'm back in neutral in this really
shitty situation
and then slowly building building it's
so funny because we just had this
conversation yesterday
um I forgot what prompted it for us to
get on this specific topic but you
you've made the comment of like you're
like you know what
life's pretty easy even that explanation
it's like oh yeah that's pretty easy
right it's like one baby step at a time
like it doesn't have to be complicated
you don't have to know everything
when it comes to saving a life you don't
have to know everything about you don't
have to know anything you just have to
have that Anchor Point and you just do
one other thing that's a slightly a
different Anchor Point you know you just
build on that momentum oh I think we
were talking about dieting yeah yeah
where you're like yeah it's uh it's that
easy because we're looking at what you
eat we're looking at our old pictures of
get lean and they're like oh [ __ ] then
we got pretty [ __ ] ripped there
like hmm when you watch what you eat
all of a sudden and you exercise you
know you get the body you want
hmm what an interesting question yeah
we're like that is [ __ ] pretty easy
yeah it's not that hard but yeah this
kind of goes back to that where I'm like
yeah that's uh pretty easy but I think
our minds are so Advanced and so complex
that we just make everything so
complicated like we're the biggest irony
yeah ourselves because I think in this
day and age and probably already for a
few decades
I literally think we have all of the
solutions to our problems
we all do like majority of them
but the only person that is getting in
the way of executing those Solutions is
US yeah ourselves like
it's pretty easy
brush your teeth every day like 60 to
120 seconds in the morning
60 to 120 seconds at night
probably won't have any cavities all of
us got [ __ ] cavities
you know like [ __ ] like that or like you
know what what was that math I was
telling you or like save 10 bucks a day
oh yeah and you're a millionaire save 10
bucks a day put it in like a eight
percent 10 compounding like ETF or stock
or something
in like 30 years you're a millionaire so
for 18 48
still young you're a millionaire
no one wants to do it you know it's just
crazy it's like we literally have all
the solutions to our problems like walk
just couple steps a day
eat less than uh then you burn
get a six pack
it's [ __ ] crazy there's just so many
yummy things out there
or like read a page a day
even read a page a day and at the end of
the year you finish one book a year how
many books have you done knowing all
this numbers and you'll be none and
you'll be one book smarter
none of us do it
yeah and I'm telling you man this leads
me to [ __ ] believe that we're just
all being controlled by some [ __ ]
money hungry [ __ ] secret society type
of [ __ ] you know what I'm talking
about like the Illuminati all of that
[ __ ] that they're just there to control
the people and I just want out I just
want to get out of it how do you get out
of it
the honestly the only way I could see
myself really getting out of it is just
unplugging disconnecting and just living
on off my own land
but which propaganda did you see to
inspire that idea
uh I don't know if it's anything I
specifically saw it's just how I feel
about everything where I feel like
everything is so unnecessary and I feel
like it just keeps getting more and more
exaggerated and
um we're pushed to purchase more and
rely on more and like oh you have this
symptom yeah you have to get on this
drug or this food now it comes in like a
cheaper version of that like it's just
everything just feels more and more
plastic and fake and unnecessary and
excessive and I'm like I don't know if
this is right like it just feels off for
me yeah
I feel the same way
but I'm super split
because I always like to look at the
movers and shakers of the world in any
direction
and um
there's that part of it
but then there's the billionaires that
are like we're gonna keep [ __ ]
crushing and moving this planet forward
and moving this species forward and I go
I wonder what they see and then there's
the minimalist sound like we're going
Way Forward too fast we need to go
backwards I wonder what they see like
that I before it was forward mean though
like in what way like the AIS movement
forward
um no because we're leaving behind us so
entrepreneurs are problem solvers right
yeah so like
um
for them they're constantly solving a
problem yeah right so it depends on the
entrepreneur so for example
um
if like we need more stuff then we need
more stuff faster so Amazon comes in you
get stuff today tomorrow whatever you
know really really fast so they're
constantly just pushing things forward
when we're like maybe I don't need that
much stuff
so there's people that are constantly
going let's solve more problems and then
there's other people we don't have that
many problems so I'm I'm trying to grasp
like what
because they both are thriving yeah at
which one fits me the most I see because
for the most part I see a lot of stuck
because I see a lot of entrepreneurs
um that I guess you've just talked about
where they're not really I don't see it
as advancing civilization or Society I
just see it as they're solving consumer
problems
and again I'm like why do we need to
consume so much but aren't we not all
consumers
uh we are but now I feel like we're at
such an excessive point now you know
like I was looking at my um I was
excessive though
because like is was it excessive in the
1950s when every gentleman had like 10
hats
did he have ten hats or do you have like
one or two I don't know but what is that
excessive true I guess it I guess it
just it's all relative or did the
excessive start with farming
yeah when we're like in the like I don't
know [ __ ] 1200s we're like you know
what instead of like frolicking in the
forest we're just gonna plant rows of
this [ __ ] yeah is that excessive true
that's that's a good point that's how I
like talking to you I always go in this
Rabbit Hole of like
um uh maybe this is where I need to
Center myself and that's what you're
like like no I'm chilling I I see it
from all angles
in this world I
I'm still trying to find the center I
don't know
because this feels like this world is
like um
like it feels like I don't have a grasp
of it and as the world advances I'm
losing the grasp of what I do so fast
but at the same time I'm also like is
that how it's supposed to be and so
we're supposed to be like the answer to
having a peaceful life is being
comfortable with the chaos yeah is that
what it's supposed to be I think we're a
different version of adults than our
parents are though right because they've
seen technological advancements and like
um they've just seen a lot of
differences right like they've evolved
we've evolved so much but I think at the
rate that we're evolving now like all of
it like uh Commerce or business or
um intelligence like the rate that we're
traveling at I feel like is way faster
than our parents generation or even like
their obviously their parents generation
I think it's all relative are you sure
yeah I mean the rate is faster
but the rate is still relative that's
true
like for us the difference between like
AI and then to what was just Google
before yeah before it's like I'm looking
up the things that I want now it's the
computer knows the things that I wanted
is giving it to me right away
that rate it's because we're already
that sophisticated to understand Google
yeah that to me is the same thing as
when like horses to cars well when you
wanted to know something
you don't know anybody like you you
literally know your neighbor like how do
I [ __ ] milk this cow and your
neighbor has to teach you to the first
Library being established and you're
like wait I think going this building
and there's a thousand books and they're
like whoa this is way too fast
internationally too much I can milk look
how the Japanese way the Austrian way I
can count so many different ways holy
[ __ ] this is what's the difference
between the Austrian way and the
Japanese way I think one's like be and
the other one's like
[ __ ] Bobby Lee
yeah I don't know I I do want to pick my
mom's brain on that because my mom comes
from a time where they were still riding
horses I think she let go already
what do you mean I'm about to let go
she's she's gonna let go no she already
been letting go anytime someone looks at
a phone like this
well it's because she can't see dude no
they already let go trust me what does
that mean let go of what so the Train on
this train of technology and advancement
Society gets faster and faster and
faster yeah yeah yeah right and there's
a certain point where someone goes [ __ ]
it yeah and then they get an Android and
then yeah and your mom is [ __ ] you I
already [ __ ] it at Tick Tock that's I
don't have one I was really like that's
you know what that's past me take it
away take it away take it away so I
already said [ __ ] it then yeah yeah yeah
yeah same type it has a much better
Mastery of tick tock than I do everyone
has a [ __ ] it face so her version of
this is already me like on Tick Tock
wait [ __ ] it
[ __ ] do I like it what would I do yeah
you're pretty bad you know what I mean
yeah so I think everyone has a version
of [ __ ] it and
it's just going to keep going faster and
if you want to stay on the train you got
to be up on all of it but if not
everyone has a point of [ __ ] it
like shoes and in fashion you know like
you you're like okay cool I'm gonna be
trendy so like I got dressed like this
then I'm gonna dress like this then I'm
dressed like this and then everyone has
like a version of like oh he [ __ ] it
in the 90s this guy [ __ ] in 2020 this
guy [ __ ] in in 2015.
if you're a chick right now and you
don't have pink or blue or [ __ ] green
hair you already [ __ ] it back in like
2015. you know what I mean guess I
haven't [ __ ] it yet well you don't
have [ __ ] pink hair I used to or you
don't have a [ __ ] septum ring
whatever the [ __ ] it's called yeah you
know like everything all Industries
Full Speed Ahead and then people I think
it just rides so fast that people are
like you know what [ __ ] it here [ __ ] it
there [ __ ] it there [ __ ] it yeah
just hearing you talk about all these
Trends and [ __ ] I'm just like [ __ ]
[ __ ] it I'm just gonna focus on
stuttering myself I think you I mean
obviously it's really sad that you're
like I had to separate myself from my
body when getting my ass beating just
[ __ ] horrendous but
it's helped you a lot helped me a lot
and the uh
the meditations like being with myself
starting when I was like I don't know
five six seven eight yeah I think that
it sounds like you're about to [ __ ]
start according
yeah you're like five six seven eight
that's [ __ ] horrible yeah it makes me
really sad but why don't you meditate
now
I think I'm [ __ ] tired of that [ __ ]
but honestly I meditate all the time
and you don't share with me you stupid
[ __ ] I think I met it no I only
meditate when [ __ ] hits the fan what
does that mean I know what [ __ ] it's a
fan but what that what does that mean I
think when I get nervous or when I get
anxiety I think that's when I like I I
practice it where I'm like I just think
of like one thought and I go okay I just
zoned it on the one thought that's
amazing and you've never shared that
with me when I'm [ __ ] freaking out
no I'm trying to take care of myself
oh my God have you tried taking care of
yourself
all the time I've never heard anyone
tell me Shut the [ __ ] up so many times
and try to take care of himself I'm like
babe shut up shut the [ __ ] up don't you
[ __ ] time
I'm like God damn all right I'm just
gonna go I don't do that I'ma just go
chill out over here by myself I don't do
that yeah don't lie you sure about that
yeah so what do you do teach me your
ways you [ __ ]
that happens the most frequently is
airplane turbulence
right because I travel a decent amount
you son of a [ __ ] I just told you how I
get so scared now of [ __ ] getting on
it but you've withheld this for me
because you told me you do what I do
what do you do
so when when it gets crazy I go
if it's my time to go it's my time to go
I'm gonna go
what happens in your brain because then
the other side goes yeah but what if you
go this way and you go this way then
what do you do I just blow the air out
and then that's done I make a decision
and that's it
you just have to make a decision with
your feelings
and how you're going to approach it you
know
you just gotta pull the trigger and
that's meditation for you yeah yeah and
then sticking to it
because meditation isn't like oh what
about that what about that one about
that that's just [ __ ] thinking and
pondering and ruminating thoughts I go
it's my time to go it's my time to go
um
I'm in that state of Zen
and then the airplane
oh my [ __ ] God but then you have to
believe what you just said yeah I
believe it
that's called making a decision
[ __ ] maybe I don't believe it now that
it's like
when you go bungee jumping right it's
like one two three make the decision
not oh [ __ ] and you're like ah you're
stuck on it you know I got a man two
three make a decision and you owe it to
yourself to commit
with anything that you do and you
learned this uh through meditation or is
this something you just came up with
that you're like because I've done
meditation I've chalked it up to and
boiled it down to this is basically it I
the meditation I think helps you get
centered but the active decision making
is something that you have to practice I
think through action uh because people
were tough I mean we're in tough
situations all the time right sometimes
you really want the car but the finances
should I get the car or whatever or I
want to talk to that girl I want to talk
that guy oh no but I'm so nervous and
then I think that act of like getting
over that hump and just committing yeah
I'm gonna walk over there and talk to
her I don't give a [ __ ] if she rejects
me I'm doing it that's an additional
practice like the thoughts the being
able to send yourself and then being
able to like almost control your flight
or fight response and always choosing
fight that has to be paired yeah that
makes sense or else if it's flight
then you're always gonna you're
technically gonna betray yourself yeah
because you're gonna be like okay and
that's where your confidence goes I got
it yeah I'm I'm [ __ ] it If I die I die
oh my God I'm gonna [ __ ] doesn't
[ __ ] so scary what the [ __ ] yeah you
just you just you broke your promise you
broke your promise and then you you went
back on what you told yourself you're
gonna do it's like
you know it's like everything saving
money like we go like go back to saying
like all the things in life saving money
I told myself I'm gonna brush my teeth
every day I told myself I'm gonna
eat less or whatever or gonna work out
every day it's the same thing the more
the more promises that you keep to
yourself the stronger that
decision-making becomes because you know
if I when I I'm the type of person like
you ought to be able to have these
thoughts in your head I'm the type of
person when I say I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna do it yeah it doesn't matter if
anybody's around you're the type of
person that keep promises to yourself
yeah I said I'm gonna make this movie
I'm gonna do it yeah but if you're the
type of person that's like I always
break my own promises then it's going to
be hard to be the trigger puller when
the [ __ ] actually hits the fan yeah and
then
it's going to be hard because you're not
your your muscle of commitment is very
low yeah yeah yeah it's very weak yeah
that's a good point and I do see that
myself in it that's uh when people are
like how are you so confident how do you
build confidence and I think that's one
of the main key drivers it's like making
the decision committing to that decision
and and being relentless with the
decision like most people I see that are
successful
this isn't their first success
you know like you're like oh Dad what
the hell is this guy like a real estate
agent what the hell this guy's like
crushing he's like way better than all
the other ones and you talk to him for a
little bit and then you find out oh this
guy play D1 basketball he went on
scholarship oh [ __ ] okay and then you
find out oh there's the other thing that
this person did oh this guy won the
science fair when he was a kid or
whatever you know it's like a like a
bunch of a whole track record of
promising beings to themselves and then
delivering on those things and then so
their muscle of commitment is so strong
yeah I like that and then it seems like
that the rest of the life is accelerated
but it's because it's built on this
Foundation you know yeah
that's so true I feel that a lot with
myself
but yeah the meditation part is really
rad I don't think I've ever really
meditated
yeah yeah what about even what about
when you're um even about to go to sleep
or when you're like a stressful moment
you don't take a moment to yourself
you're just talking to yourself
uh if I'm super stressed and I have the
the luxury of time to sit there and like
unpack all of it I will
meditation gets better
the more you do it what do you mean so
for someone might that's starting they
might need like
quite a moment to get centered or in
their like Zen state if you've done it a
lot you can get centered like that it's
like like an MMA fighter right like GSP
in between rounds is back to resting
heart rate versus someone like me if I
do a peak workout it might take me like
30 minutes laying on the floor before
I'm like
whereas GSP is a little like ding ding
when his heart rate is like so I think
the more you do it the faster you hit
that like Baseline yeah I've tried it it
just never um and I hear so many good
things about it I don't know I don't
know if I have the patience for it or
maybe because it's not happening quickly
enough for me that it's not I just don't
gravitate towards it or I don't know
what it is but I've tried it a few times
different styles of it and nothing
really sticks
a fun one is the cold showers or cold
Plunge
uh that's a that's a form of meditation
so
they have like the physiological
benefits of it
um but in my opinion the true benefit of
that is it's forcing people to meditate
it's giving them every present honestly
it's giving them a fun way to do it yeah
because like the minute the water
splashes on you when it's coldly bottle
filter like our first initial is gasp
and then if you're in the water for long
enough you're like
now that someone else is controlling the
way you breathe but then the first uh
way of centering yourself is creating
that insulated Gap right like your be
your own Hydro Flask yeah yeah so when
the water hits you you're like
and then pretty soon your breathing gets
smoother and smoother and smoother
there's not like the little Shivers and
then pretty soon you're just like
oh [ __ ] that's tight so that's in my
opinion that's truly the benefit of cold
showers cold plunges is giving people a
a uh physical way of met of meditating
yeah before they understand how to do it
mentally uh that's really cool yeah I've
heard a lot of people that have been um
battling with depression when they don't
want to get medicated when they're like
wait wait I want to try and stress out
every other alternative before I resort
to that
um cold plunge has been something that
has been helping people I'm not saying
that
um to go that route but I've just I've
just seen people do alternative things I
know medication for some is perfect you
know but
um and I think it could be that effect
where it's like because you know you
might not be president or these thoughts
are creeping in that you just really
need to Center yourself and that gets
you there quick because you're just like
[ __ ] this is [ __ ] cold I
don't give a [ __ ] if I feel like I'm all
alone
right now I feel alive yeah yeah because
it helps you Center yourself yeah
because it's a I think a lot of the
stuff that people deal with these days
like the demons in their brain it has to
do with not being able to clear the room
when you need to yeah and meditation
helps you be able to like okay everyone
everyone go home yeah yeah yeah like you
pull out your own couch and you get to
chill in your own brain I don't think
people do that enough so it's always all
these unwanted guests all the time and
they are forcing these uncomfortable
situations but when it's cold those
[ __ ] clear off fast yeah yeah
where you at [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] boom all
that [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] about
my car payment I don't care I'm
overdoing taxes yeah [ __ ] as [ __ ] yep
I'm here in the moment now yeah that's
tight I want to start doing that cold
showers yeah uh no the plunge I feel
like the shower it's too much of an easy
out
that's also but that's also what makes
it kind of dope yeah because then it's
like you have the [ __ ] you can ring
the bell there you know it's on you if
you take a left another thing fine
another thing is it doesn't get cold
enough like it gets cold but I'm like I
can give me like a minute like I'm fine
the other thing I would say to that
though is let's say if I was coaching
you I would say don't ever wait
people wait for the perfect time place
machine equipment whatever to do what
they want to do and that never happens
people I'm gonna do the cold plunge all
right for sure and they're like okay I'm
gonna go look oh [ __ ] it's like 300
bucks damn I gotta go save him some
money yeah yeah and they never get to it
yeah get the garden hose spray yourself
where you're the most sensitive and time
yourself for 30 seconds in my heart how
do I get there right there
but literally spray yourself with like
the some of the best benefits like in
talking about the whole consumerism
thing
a lot of the soup the solutions that we
see now
it's already there
it's just right now through technology I
think we're squeezing the last drop out
of it so like you can technically grab
ice from your fridge and just throw it
in your corner crotch
you know what I mean that's free yeah
yeah we want to do things the
comfortable way of cold plunging yeah
yeah and the cool way in the social
media way yeah or go to Home Depot buy a
thing fill it up with water just jump in
there yeah throw some [ __ ] I go to
get five dollar Ice Cube bags or wait
till it's night time and take off your
clothes in their backyard and lay on the
concrete like there's a lot of ways to
do it yeah
um but I would say like always think
resourceful rather than spending money
and yeah perfect time Perfect Place
perfect people because those are
technically your own little
handicaps and softening the blow yeah
that's true like I'm gonna wait till I
find a book I like no [ __ ] read
anything right now yeah find any book it
could be even something that you
disagree with you could be [ __ ]
Buddhist go find the Bible start reading
yeah get in because the main thing is
getting uh the muscle of doing that yeah
people always forget they think it's the
destination it's the the journey right
and the journey builds the muscle yeah
yeah like running the marathon isn't
gonna make you a strong Runner loving
running makes you a strong Runner and
now you're good at marathons yeah it's
the other way around yeah that's so true
I hate when you're right I'm always
right I think sometimes
all right dude you know what else is
right
me the right time
to end the podcast is that good yeah
that's pretty good thank you so much and
on that note folks thank you so much for
listening we'll see you next week bye
bye